[Applause]
so the Supreme Court's going to hand out
early we're very encouraged by the
lengthy discussion at the end
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
the judgment side of the brexit divide
me around
we worry about a welding which a Prime
Minister and suspend Parliament as an
inconvenience those who support origins
actions at the moment should be asking
themselves the question how they would
feel about the future labour Prime
Minister perhaps Jeremy Corbyn who did
not any longer watch to be subject to
the constraints that Parliament might
place upon his act
how would they feel about this this is
not an issue about this is an issue
about what people change when Lord Robin
Jung said it's not the job of the
judiciary to politically scrutinize the
government's is the job of Parliament an
MP's like myself to be speech
[Music]
[Applause]
the Scottish Court have already
addressed why that's not the case and of
course at large panic can't you see
marjina Miller and our own legal team
led by if you nail QC have invited the
Supreme Court to follow the persuasive
reasoning of the Supreme Court of
Scotland that this is legality a matter
of upholding democracy and a matter of
upholding the rule of law can I just at
this point it's very very difficult for
me to understand how it can be said to
be political for the Supreme Court to
stop the prime minister suspending
Parliament but not permissible for the
Supreme Court to allow the Prime
Minister suspended
what if sauce for the goose is sauce for
the gander plainly bearer political
consequences whichever way the court to
decide but what is at stake here is a
fundamental
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
but we are not currently in the normal
world you see it's more to say in French
performance where Prime Minister with no
majority has French in Parliament will
be sketching in this way so I wish folks
can be the consequences of their
decisions and should they find an
artfully part
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
an MP should be able to bring urgent
questions and urgent debates as they did
before part of it should go back to its
normal child in a normal functioning
democracy of holding the government to
account as to my constituents elected me
to do that when they elated my
colleagues who brought this action to
you and know about screaming and
shouting is going to prevent us from
doing that
you have to find your dirty tricks from
Boris Johnson there is a period of five
days prescribed by the Northern Ireland
Executive for Meister now it begins if I
recall correctly on the 14th of October
during which Parliament will sit and
those five days might well be used by
Parliament to enact emergency
legislation to remove the critic - the
right to treat Parliament as a mere
inconvenience that he can set aside when
politically use those valuable five days
[Music]
under the terms of the 2018 withdrawal
that there is an awful lot to do the
protecting substantial period of time
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]